so everybody's got to go they even have
strategies in doing this in action but
the one thing I discovered is hear
people want to I'm going to make this up
triple their business let's say and so
they have all the goals the doing this
all of that set except the one thing
that they're not doing is okay but wait
a minute Mr CEO or Mrs CEO what about
how you've never produced tripling your
business your leaders have never
produced tripling the business I'm clear
you want to Triple your business and you
even have strategies for it but if you
don't uplevel your leaders and who
they're being to equal triple the
business yeah you might as well cancel
it now because it ain't happening so no
one works on who are you going to be
being who are you going to be by the end
of 2023 that you're currently not that
is equal to whatever the new numbers are
in the company that everybody wants
all right believe Nation this is a very
exciting uh round two with Beth hendel
from kibbutzenko the name of this show
might be tell me tell me why I suck or
tell me where I suck because because I
love Beth this is round two she's at a
an amazing executive coach blew my mind
the first time that we connected about a
year ago and I just re-watched our
episode and uh it was so good you're so
good Beth it was so good the biggest
thing that came to me was that whole
idea from great ideas come to me I don't
know if you remember our session but I I
like she's like whatever another session
I had tons of people but I deeply
remember the session that I wrote about
you in my new book
what did you write what did I write well
I won't read congratulations
congratulations on your book first of
all thank you okay so I talked about
Beth hendel and that we did a live
coaching session and and I said I told
her that I'm able to be productive
because I make a plan and then I believe
in the plan when I wake up I don't have
to think I just have to believe in the
plan and then if something comes up that
makes me question the plan I created an
adjusted plan and then I believe in the
plan again that's where I'm living most
of the time I told Beth that what
happens sometimes is that I lose faith
in the plane and I also can't come up
with a new plan I've built my identity
around being the guy who believes in the
plan so instead of having my entire
identity crumble before me as a coping
mechanism I'll naturally tell myself
great things come to me that was my big
takeaway from my first session I want to
plan I feel like I need a plan but I
can't come up with one in the moments so
I ignore it for now because great things
come to me I always felt that it was a
crutch I was falling on something I
wasn't proud of because my identity was
tied coming up with great plans but it
at least allowed me to move forward then
Beth changed my life
it's word for word this is in here
awesome and there's a little more but
but we'll stop there but it had a
profound impact on me our our hour
together so I'm excited nervous to be
back for round two and
um I don't know exactly where to go but
I can give you a quick update yeah so
give me an update well and from the
update Evan and this is for everyone
listening you're looking for there's
everything that's incredible in your
life that you're making magic in that
the universe is delivering results
inside of and then there's wherever in
your life that's not happening and so
where I go in is to where your dreams
aren't happening
um and make sure you've got a dream in
there and then have that happen so in
your update include what isn't making
Magic
okay so great things come to me I'm
still on the same Mission as it was
before I wanna I wanna solve the world's
biggest problem people don't believe
themselves enough so this this is the
new challenge and you you encouraged me
to have some kind of number to shoot
towards and so I'm at you know three and
a half million subscribers I want to get
the 35
uh it's never been done before uh
everybody if you look at the whole
personal industry if you take like
garyvee and Grant Cardone Robbins and
Tony Robbins and Tom bill you like
combined they don't have it's not this
they don't have 35 million so so we're
like reaching into brand new territory
living in the dream which was you know
again the thing you encouraged me to do
and uh that's the new kind of
quantifiable goal that I'm chasing down
the great things come to me
um one of the biggest habits that I
picked up is door frames so every time I
walk into a room
I'll hit the door frame and just
mentally say great things come to me
so and if I miss a door frame like I
went to go see my wife and said I'm
talking to Beth she's the great things
come to me woman I forgot to hit the
door for him on the way in so as I come
back here like I mentally tap it twice
in my head in and out great things come
to me so when we first talked we talked
about the warrior who has no belief then
then the
the Evan who believes in his calendar
and then the Evan who believes in his
dream and I was about 10 no belief 80
belief in the calendar and 10 belief in
the dream and if I had to self-assess
now where are we I'd say it's five
percent no belief so we've we've leashed
you know the warrior a little bit more
love it yeah
um using some of your lingo 70 belief in
the calendar and then 25 belief in a
dream so like 10 to 25 and belief in the
dream not not living there yet but uh
constant work in progress and excited to
talk to you again and level up and uh
okay good all right let's see where I'm
going okay good so you know this
interesting thing and I'm going to
create a context Evan first before I
then give you what I want you to do
um so an interesting thing as an
executive life coach over the last this
first quarter so we're in the first
quarter of the year I've been going into
many different companies
um and doing sessions with the teams
because what I have found that's been
missing in the companies is everyone's
got their kpis their okrs their big
goals like yours 35 million right so
everybody's got the goal they even have
strategies in doing this in action
but the one thing I discovered is here
people want to I'm going to make this up
triple their business let's say and so
they have all the goals the doing this
all of that sect except the one thing
that they're not doing is okay but wait
a minute Mr CEO or Mrs CEO
what about how you've never produced
tripling your business
your leaders have never produced
tripling the business I'm clear you want
to Triple your business and you even
have strategies for it but if you don't
uplevel your leaders and who they're
being to equal triple the business yeah
you might as well cancel it now because
it ain't happening so no one works on
who are you going to be being who are
you going to be by the end of 2023 that
you're currently not
that is equal to whatever the new
numbers are in the company that
everybody wants and so I've been doing
sessions with teams on all right let's
invent the beingness because watch
first there's being who are you going to
be then that gives you what to do from
who you invented yourself to be and then
you will have results consistent with
who you're being
forget it the doing this everyone's
doing doing doing
I go to work on who you're going to be
so for your 35 million
you have to invent the ebbing that
you're currently not
and not in a bad thing you just never
had 35 million so you have to invent in
Evan that is equal to the 35 million
because the Evan that you currently are
has 3.5 million rock on congratulations
but it ain't 35 million
so I would here's the question
by the end of 2023
who's Evan gonna be that you're
currently not
so I'm going to tell you mine okay
I started to invent the new Beth at the
end of last year I had just been through
the resignation of Handel they're
getting out of and breaking up with my
sister horrible right horrible the whole
thing was horrible except I picked my
soul over anything else and I know that
my soul would win and then by the end of
the year I'm like okay I healed I did
what I needed to do and now who am I
gonna be for 2023 that I'm currently not
so I would never say I'm a great coach
because I am I would never say I'm
organized cause I'm anal repentive right
like duh so here's who I invented myself
to be that I'm not gentle
I don't have a gentle bone in my
freaking body
and when I called my daughter Max 21
years old and said Maxie I am so sorry I
raised you without a gentle bone in my
body she said I'm starting to cry mommy
I'm not gentle either I said I know I
messed you up so we will learn this
gentle together so gentle
also gracefully let go of things not
meant for me
I don't let go of things I want to
manage and control everything
so gracefully let go and then the third
one is my voice because I spent my years
underneath my sister's Voice versus my
voice
my magic
and I invented that at the end of the
year and then I'll teach you what you do
to make sure it happens and that's who
I'm being and the results of the number
of clients I have the love of my life
showed up like the magic that came from
the reinvention of me
so the question for you Evan is Who you
gonna be
by the end of 2023 that you're currently
not it can't be anything negative so you
can't say oh I'm gonna not be a
procrastinator I'm not saying you are oh
I'm not going to be anxious or I'm not
going to be a warrior no who are you
going to be
by the end of the year I'm gentle I'm
loving big I'm gracefully letting go of
things not meant for me I it's my voice
all of which I'm currently none of
and then I spend every day
in my having designed my day with all
those in there and then I report at the
end of the day oh I was not gentle with
myself today I was a big Gruff with this
thing so you then want to then find all
the places where you're not being him so
you can bring the new to him does that
make sense Evan
all right so this is your chance I'm
going to be quiet now for you to give me
who you're going to be the evolution of
you
that would for sure allow for the 35
million in the movement of that
right so that by the end of this year
let's say you're at 10 million
on your way to 35 million
and the evolution of you and then next
year you're going to have to reinvent
yourself again
well first off congratulations on
finding the love of your life because we
talked about that a little bit last time
where you said you're in your 60s and
what you look great for by the way and
uh and single and you don't want to tell
yourself the story that you'll never
find the person and you're going to
manifest it and 11 months later you've
manifested it so this is great it's
happening no totally I hope that it
works exactly it totally works okay who
am I gonna be
and it goes I am it's like an I am
statement I am okay I am constantly
looking for 10x opportunities
I'm gonna I'm gonna tweak it but give me
the give them to me now yeah oh I don't
even know what I'm just I'm just riffing
so let's tweak together inside let's
take that one I'm constantly looking for
opportunities right well 10x
opportunities because that's the goal is
a 10x to go next opportunities so why
watch it's not I am looking for them
right it is 10x opportunities come to me
oh okay so we're not doing I am okay so
no but it's inside of the statement of I
am it's I'm just saying I am so it's not
I'm gonna be one day I will be it's more
from the place it's done so you're
saying it's done so it could be some
version of 10x opportunities find me on
a daily basis like before being that
human that I attract look at all the
peop all the 10x opportunities that come
to me got it I like your gracefully let
go of things that are meant for me I
might take that absolutely you know what
it came from a Buddha quote in the end
only three things matter
how much you loved how gently you lived
and how gracefully you let go of things
not meant for you Buddha that's what I
read that that's where I invented who I
am I'm like I love big gently lived and
gracefully you took all three of them
Beth and Buddha together I love it
that's great Isn't that cool yeah it's
fabulous okay so you take that one too
gracefully let go of things not meant
for me love that something around still
you know the belief in the dream I I
Believe In The Dream more than the
calendar
whatever I believe I prove so I believe
that
I think you know what I teach right is
whatever you believe you prove that's
part of what's happening with you is you
really do believe great things come to
you
there are other people on this planet
who are like I just got off the phone
with someone I'm coaching who believes
she sucks right and I've got to get her
out of that to where you are called
great things always come to me you made
that up
and you believed it and you proved it so
everyone who's listening whatever you
believe you proved since we make it all
up you might as well come up with
something you like
so so I believe that you know the
self-assessment at the beginning I
believe great things come to me
25 of the time
let's invent so by the end of the year
by the end of the year conversion of the
only way I live
is believing in things some version of
that so because you're 25 will not get
you 35 million you need a hundred
percent of believing that great things
always come to you so you could say that
by the end of the year you've upped the
ante On Believing in great things always
come to you
yeah I I just like even that great
things always come to me that's good I
love that I think that should be
great things always come to me yes
because what's going to happen Evan and
everyone when you invent who you're
being
you're not going to wake up tomorrow
morning and be him or her I mean I wish
that I woke up after 64 years and I'm
now gentle
and the first one I saw I was in my
closet and one of my sweaters got stuck
on a hanger and I went like this
and then I went oh my God I'm not gentle
in anything I do
but I needed to see her
I needed to see every day how much I'm
gruffing a Gangster on myself mostly
I've stopped doing that on other people
I'm just on my own self I'm brutal
and so you want to be able to see that
and then when you take on gracefully
letting go of things that don't belong
that aren't meant for you
I spent a week seeing how much I want to
manage everybody
my daughter who hangs up on me because
she doesn't want me to manage art right
like I want him out I should manage her
right no no Beth Let It Go so all you're
going to see Evan in taking on like the
you know 10x opportunities always come
to me gracefully letting go of things
not meant for me great things always
come to me as you're going to see
how you don't live there constantly and
what where you go with those you're
going to see the loops the negative
Loops that come in
that take you out of being him which you
need to see obviously we're doing this
on the spot so you should take this as
like homework and go truly invent your
beingness of who you're going to be that
the evolution of such that 35 million
you're in the game yeah no no it's great
after this I'm going to take my my New
York uh coffee mug and then do some more
reflection time but this this is great
you're feeling you're filling my brain I
probably put something about leadership
you know we've got a bunch of people on
the team now and guiding them leading
them trusting them uh encouraging them
are you inventing yourself to be
spending more time with them I don't
know what we put that as
um
and giving up more projects so
um I am someone who delegates
and nurtures and empowers my team on a
regular basis
I let go of things I Empower my team to
take things off my plate
I find and encourage the who
instead of focusing on the how yeah
don't have the negative so if you're not
focusing on the how you 'd say my sister
Marnie invented this the how
and then for those of you listening what
I mean by that is in the invention of
manifesting we all create the dream and
the scene and what we want and what we
desire but what screws the dream is you
immediately go into but how am I going
to do that and the moment you go into
how you just went from flying up in the
trees with your dream down to the Earth
and it kills the dream do not go to how
you actually leave that bee just hang
out in the dream of who you are and let
the universe work for you
that doesn't mean sit around and don't
do anything but you don't need to know
how you're going to get to 35 million
yeah
that's your number
I let the universe work for me that's a
good one yeah no and most people don't
let the universe work for you and that
is for those of you whether you say God
or Source the universe God not religion
Universe Source Works wants to help
wants to work for us if you let them
have you ever done um and I'll say this
to everyone because I love it and I
don't get paid for this
but have you ever done the Dr Joe to
spend some meditations yes yeah he I
just fell in love with him specifically
his book breaking the habit of being
yourself
and he's got I bought the four
meditations that go with that book on
breaking the habit of being yourself and
that is what altered me
I swear
that helped me heal and everything and
brought the man in and everything so if
you for everyone who's listening if you
have not done the Joe dispenza
meditations and specifically the ones on
breaking the habit of being yourself do
them they're life-altering
and I don't advertise for him I've never
met him I don't get paid I'm just
telling you what's good for you
I like homework yes I would definitely
go do those okay great against this
whole Quantum field that's magical
that's all I'll say about it
go find out all right so what do we've
got so wait go back to the one with your
team so how do you want to say
empowering your team
but I find it encourage the who
okay good so I find and encourage the
hoe you'll either say how if you want to
write anything else so you got your
leadership you've got your 10x
opportunities you've got letting go of
things and you've got the upping the
ante on great things come to you and
then I put I'll let the universe work
for me yes awesome which is perfect
because the dispenza meditations will
validate that
with the quantum field
okay yeah all right what else we got now
okay so now from the beingness
which no one ever works on but that's
what you need to work on versus just
your goals you got goals but it's also
whatever goals you have they're more
than you had last year you've got to
reinvent yourself that is a yes so then
now you've invented who you're being so
now you've got to put in
some actions to become him
so there's as you know with me there's
three things you need to move something
forward you need a specific measurable
promise
you need an incentive because you're not
going to want to do it and I like silly
or annoying incentives
and you need an accountability buddy
your wife someone on your team
and Evan just so you know and I'm going
to coach you to do this given you're now
a leader and have a team
if you want your team to produce more
than they've ever produced for you you
need them to invent who they're going to
be by the end of the year that they're
currently not
and then you part of your management and
empowerment of them is that so if I were
managing you and you're on my team I
would know who you're being and I would
go all right what's happening with the
10x opportunities how you doing with
gracefully letting things go I would
manage who you're being not just your
actions
so please put your team in this and then
the only thing I would do next is I'd
have you pick
one for the rest of March one of these
beings that you created that's the one
to take on for the month like do not
take all these on
you could take like two on
so that you get the thing moving so
which two do you want to take on first
I'm an achiever Beth I don't like just
taking on two okay we'll go with the 10x
opportunities come to me yeah and we'll
go with I find and encourage the who so
now what you want to do is you want to
make a promise likely you're going to
need an incentive and then your
accountability buddy so if you've got I
find and encourage the hoe given what
you said I could hear the cavity of that
you don't meet with them enough
your new promise could be specific
measurable would be I will meet I'm
making this up you pick I will meet with
my team for an hour every other week
can I ask you something yeah kind of
hedged on my on my pick those are like
the the I find it encouraged who is like
the easiest one is that good or should I
go for the harder one no I don't want to
go for the harder one now all right good
so switch it up which one
I let the universe work for me that's a
hard one okay good and then which other
one the 10x so yeah we'll keep with the
10x yeah yeah okay good okay every day
you would create in your meditation or
however you create like
I wonder who the universe is sending me
today
I wonder what 10x opportunities come in
my way today
so you're like I have in my design day
like look who came to hire me today
I don't do any work as in like gold cold
cold call or oh I'm like look who came
to me today and the other day someone
from four years ago that I coached a
husband and wife came out of the blue
like we found you we want Joe and I'm
like
they find me I don't have to do anything
because I believe that and then there's
some days like yesterday no one came for
me so in my day I wrote to the gang I'm
like they're coming didn't have anybody
today it's not like oh I failed it's
seeing
how I do each day like a scorecard some
days I do great some days I suck who
cares I got the next day
what do you normally do for looking for
10x opportunities
what have you done I'm mostly kind of
buried in my plan so there's not a
there's not enough time to like look
outside okay good so there it is I got
it now so here's your promise can you
promise on a weekly basis you pick the
day you pick the number of days and the
amount of time but some version of every
day Monday through Friday I spend an
hour playing in 10x opportunities
looking for can you so you need a
promise like that so that the Universe
gets you're serious about it
so make a promise of each day 30 minutes
each three days a week an hour each some
promise like that with an accountability
buddy okay
again you want to do this with your team
once they invent to their being like
what's their promise who's their buddy
okay so that's that one then let the
universe work for me so first do you
believe the universe does work for you
kinda
Okay so
uh what I would do to get this one your
specific measurable promise would be I
do the Joe dispensive meditation
one a day or some version of that
because that's where you first have to
get
you have to believe that see I really
believe that
and so it does work for me I have a
client
um who questions whether the universe
works for him
so it doesn't
and I can't make them believe that right
um so he doesn't he thinks it's all him
although I think I've cracked a little
into it so we'll see all right so I
would do like meditation to start
believing in that and once you do the
Joe dispenza if you really do it
you will believe this
and what do you mean by really do it
as in their 35 minute they're four
meditations they're 35 minutes each you
would do one daily
until you really land in uh-huh yeah I I
loved it and then in there given what he
does in the meditations he's going to
get you to get to start looking for the
evidence from the quantum field
that shows you you're on the right path
with your new being and you have no clue
how that's going to show up
none like it shows up like I did he did
a whole creation on genius and having
your Genius in the world so I was just
like yeah my 15 hours a week with
clients they love me that was as much as
I did on that one right and the quantum
field with the universe sent me instead
was an Amazon Prime TV show that got
green lit that likely I'm going to be
going on to be a coach I'm like I would
have never come up with that
but that was the universe where they
said oh you want to impact the world all
right uh how about Amazon Prime
now whether it happened but that showed
up right
let's go I love it exactly exactly so
that's what you're working for for
yourself okay
anything else you need we're set with
this like you've got the two things
you're taking on I know you not that you
need a promise and an incentive and a
buddy clear I got you're in the
meditations
and I also know you're clear that if you
don't work on who people are being you
ain't having the result you're looking
for
because okay goals that are bigger than
humans that have ever produced they're
not going to produce them being the same
way that they were last year
yeah I I mean I think the the biggest
thing is the
the consistency in the thinking
not so much to like consistent action we
talked about this last time like I'll
get it done it happens it's in my
calendar and I live I like I believe in
the plan so you give me a plan I do the
plan yes so the action will happen it's
the consistency in the thinking of how
to turn that
even so I'll do the work I'll do the Joe
dispenza we'll walk for outside for 35
minutes or sit down whatever listen to
The Meditation and go and then
or or maybe strategies or ideas of how
to keep it consistent throughout the day
so it's not just a morning thing yeah
you're good with all of that yes but and
the thing for you is that while I love
your doingness and can count on you to
have the Integrity of doing what you say
you're gonna do you have to get that
what's as important
as you have for the doingness like you
put a lot of effort into honoring what
you say and doing which I applaud you
you must put as much in for your
beingness
and that's where we all fall short
so because what we do is try to get
everyone to be great doers
and great doors are great I would hire
any one of the great doers because I
know I can train them in the beingness
right so you can't it's harder to drain
people to be great doers so you're a
great doer Rock the frig on you want to
be equally great in who you're being
and taking that on they go together they
do and then you have the results okay
yeah and that's the that was the
intention behind the like great things
come to me like hit the door frame when
I walk in it's like oh it's a trigger
like to how to trigger the the being I
suppose you're getting locked into just
the doing yeah no beautiful beautiful
and now
announce for your beingness so I would
definitely write up beautifully your who
you're being you can send it to me if
you want and then you're taking these
two things on for March if you get good
at them and you're digging what's
happening with them then take another
one on
right you don't have to take them all on
because remember what not remember in
your working on the 10x opportunities
and the universe works for you that'll
cover some other stuff too like you're
the moment you go to work on your
beingness
Watch What Happens
it just does
it just does that's where I triple
people's businesses
you gotta have both people don't work on
that I did a two-hour session yesterday
with 20 people in a startup company
because they're all doing doing doing
doing but they're not going to make it
in this company because they're not but
I did a whole being and people was like
giving them water it was like this is so
great and the CEO wrote me like oh my
God Beth they're like flying yes
you need both
there's a great line from a song that
says I didn't know that I was starving
until I tasted you
which which reminds me you know of our
first conversation on this one too is
like oh that's what was missing like I
was actually starving but I didn't know
until I met you no exactly right or I
didn't know I was being managed by a
narcissist till I was out
right so yeah exactly beautiful
all right I got my marching orders I got
my homework people who want to dive
deeper into your world whether Beth
hendel Instagram or kibbutz and Co like
where do you want them to go that
pandell underscore coach Instagram DM me
if you wanna
um have a consult with me come see me
I'm live on Tuesdays
um Instagram live every Tuesday at noon
where I drop coaching last week we did
triggers I don't know what I'm gonna do
this week
um coming up but yes Evan always a
complete pleasure always thank you Beth
and thank you I'm in your book oh my God
that's all when did you did your book
already drop yeah I recently came out
yeah yeah what's it called it's called
Uh momentum all right I'm gonna go get
it momentum yeah momentum all right
awesome congratulations 35 million Evan
come on let's go we're doing it thank
you both appreciate you another quarter
all right okay bye to see my last
one-on-one with Beth check the video
right there next to me I think you'll
love it continue to believe and I'll see
you there 80 of a human being's inner
dialogue is negative one of the things
that human being sucks at besides
dreaming is the ability to keep promises
to ourselves